foreign
is starting off this hour in Nashville
hi Kevin welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
got a question about uh the dollar
assuming the record inflation and uh
the brics Nations
and uh
come across some information recently
that there's highly anticipated Summit
that they're doing on October 20 or
August 22nd
and uh people are expecting them to
announce their own
gold-backed currency they say these five
nations represent
40 percent
of uh Global GDP and Saudi Arabia is
throwing their hat in the ring with them
so the rumors are if Saudi joins them
and drops the dollar then we lose the
petrol Dollar in every country that
holds treasury bonds to buy oil from the
Saudis it's their dollars and all those
dollars come home and cause catastrophic
inflation
um
how much of this is substantial what do
you think about bricks is is there any
real threat here or anything to do to
prepare or is it just another passing
bit of fear-mongering
well I I think the um there's a lot of
discussion about it particularly uh if
you read too much on the internet but
the uh um
my you know you're asking my opinion and
that's worth really everything you're
paying for it um the uh uh
my opinion is that Russia and China
uh probably can't get the Saudis to the
table because the Saudis are probably
way too smart to think they're going to
undermine the U.S economy oh by the way
undermining the US economy would not be
profitable for all of those other
companies countries because they're
supported by the US economy
um and so if 40 percent of the GDP kills
60 of the GDP
kind of kills the whole thing it's God
is stupid
so uh no they're not going to kill
themselves by killing us that's
economically uh it's just it's it's it's
counterproductive and the idea that you
can get all of those Communists to line
up and not try to shoot each other
is going to be humorous on the Long play
they might be able to do it in one day
in August but are they actually going to
pull this off listen they couldn't pull
the Euro Euro off in Europe
to the level that it had any effect on
anything
and those people all get along
versus the group you're talking about so
I think it's a you know I they they're
working on it but I don't think that the
chances that it's going to change your
life or change my life is there
personally if it did do everything
you're talking about I don't prepare for
meteorites
I don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite strikes the Earth and kills
everything I don't have a plan for that
and I'll have a plan for Apocalypse like
you're talking about so uh there's not
one by the way because what you have
then is you have a total economic and
governmental collapse and the only plan
then that works is bottled water and
bullets
uh gold is a joke because no one trades
gold bars in the middle of a collapsed
economy and certainly no one trades
paper money in a collapsed economy but
the US government our way of life as we
know it private property rights as we
know it all the real estate I own would
be taken by the next guy with a gun
and so uh you know bullets and water is
how you'd survive I guess but I just
don't believe I'm not I I am not
stockpiling either
uh except that bullets go up too fast in
price and I shoot a lot but but that's
not that's your role but the the so all
that to say I'm not sitting and wringing
my hands over it I do have some
um friends that spend too much time
reading that crap that are ringing their
hands over it uh but I I had a big
argument with one of them the other
night I'm like dude you really need to
get off the internet yeah um and so uh
because you can't a you can't do
anything about it if it actually all
unfolded the way you did but B the
theory is broken and the broken parts of
the theory is that you can get all these
people to agree
and number and stay agreed because
they're evil at their core evil people
cannot continually agree because they
serve themselves and don't serve others
and so it can't you can't find unity in
that long term number two
if they represent 40 of the economy and
they use 40 of the world's economy which
I'm not sure that number is accurate I
think that's pretty high but if it was
that and if for and if they destroyed
sixty percent of the economy by doing
this
then they've destroyed themselves in the
process because they everything they do
hinges on the you freaking s hello I
mean it really does and that's that's
just that's economic mathematics so now
I'm not worried about it I'm a I'm a
control the controllables type gal yeah
you know like you that's like one of
those Serenity Prayer moments where it's
like I just need the serenity to realize
I can't control this I'm not I have no
idea if there's aliens yeah yeah and
UFOs and if they take over I mean I
guess I'm gonna call Will Smith because
I don't you know I don't I can't I can't
I don't have a plan for that one you
know yeah I don't control what Saudi
Arabia only aliens I'm guessing there's
no idea I don't know yeah it looks or
somebody throws a lot of Frisbees in
front of cameras Oh there's aliens but
you know I have no idea and you know
what I'm the time I'm gonna spend
worrying about it is really close to
zero Kevin I
close to zero so
I appreciate your question and it was
Earnest and honest question I honestly
do not spend any of my
time planning my personal finances or my
life around the end of the world that's
right into the world scenarios and I
have also made one other promise a lot
of guys in the financial World when they
get old like me they write the end of
the world financial book there's
something about people in my world
they're not going to predict the end
they get they get paranoid and they
predict the end of the economy they
predict the end of the world and there's
a lot of old Financial people that did
that and I'm not going to do that one
either I told my kids take to unplug the
computer if I start writing about the
end of the financial world so I'm I'm
the glass half full control the
controllables yeah I think we're going
to be okay and I'm not making fun of you
Kevin it's an honest question and the
numbers you gave me were very precise
and accurate and other than I think
those guys are overstating
well of course they over 30 they're
Russians they're over their egos they
overstate everything I mean the only
bigger drama queen than a Russian and is
an American so I mean they're drama
queens so of course they're acting like
they're got something they haven't got
yeah you know they're starving the
freaking death the whole thing the whole
communism thing oh here's a here's
another one for you read an incredible
Economist the other day said in 20 years
you ain't got to worry anything about
China you know why
they got no workers
that's right good birth rate hasn't been
negative for two decades yeah because
they're controlling the the birth rate
and so the number of people that are
going to be eligible in the workforce is
gone that's a very good point so their
ability to be a major economic player in
25 years very low they killed themselves
with their birth rate wow this is the
Ramsay show